today is October 1st 2023 so it's time
for another monthly update video I'm
going to talk about what went on in the
month of September and what we've got
coming up in October and it's kind of
big news all around I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
and the ones that I've got this time
around are indeed quite biggies so big
thing number one it took nine and a half
years but I have finished the half hour
Hegel commentary video project with uh
375 videos in the series I'll talk a
little bit more about that in the
September thing because we do want to
celebrate that achievement
big thing number two uh every October
sometimes bleeding into November we have
stoicon and stoic week I am not
organizing stoicon along with my wife
Andy Shaka this time around we did the
last two years but I will be speaking at
stoicon 2023 talking about things of
beauty so that's the theme for the
entire conference we'll talk a bit about
a little bit more about that in the
October section as well and one more
really big thing at least big to me
coming up in October and it is a um
going back on Jimmy nutt's channel for a
live stream
uh in his chatting with nuts series
which is quite good you should
definitely check it out and we're going
to be talking about something that I'm
really fascinated by and that is the
role that the Oracle or the book of
changes the eging plays in his novel man
in the High Castle and so there's a lot
involved there so those are the big
things coming up we've got a lot of
other cool things as well
so what went on in September as I
mentioned I brought the half hour Hegel
project finally to a successful close
releasing the last of the videos a while
back and then we also had an online
Hegel party to celebrate that did a live
streaming event and you know we did our
usual Hegel meetups during that which
are going to be coming to a close as
well with the ending of the project I
did my AMA as I do every month we uh
managed to get one
episode of wisdom for Life produced me
and my co-host Dan Hayes we're hoping to
get back to a more regular schedule but
getting one in was was quite good and
the world's a speculative fiction this
time around turned out quite well I was
a little bit worried because I found the
video uh on Thomas legati getting longer
and longer and longer it might be one of
the longest that I've produced in the
series it came in at over two hours but
it was very very well received by people
who have been reading and appreciating
lagatti's work much more deeply and At
You Know Much Greater length than I
myself have so that was kind of a nice
confirmation that I got there it's been
a very busy month with classes I have
four different classes ongoing at uh
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and at Marquette diversity
a lot of work with clients as well and
I've been doing some writing projects
and I think you may have seen that I'm
now you know sort of in full swing doing
a lot of volunteer work with almost home
cat Refuge
um you know it's very nice to go in
there and see the cats sometimes I
actually take my oldest child's cat in
there with me on Sundays as kind of a
thing that we we do but I also do a lot
of cleaning and feeding and taking care
of the cats and all of that sort of
stuff and I'm doing along with Andy some
Grant works for that that uh
organization as well I've also had some
medical issues this month my uh you know
I've had to be in the ER briefly and
things like that everything is basically
under control at this point but um it's
been no fun I can tell you that has been
a little bit of a disruption to my
schedule but I did manage to get a lot
of video work done this last month
including of course the three half hour
Hegel videos that brought the series to
a close I did two ideas that matter
interviews one with Jimmy Nutz who I've
already mentioned and that was about
speculative fiction but also about pro
wrestling he he was a pro wrestler for
10 years and the other was with George
grombacher who is the producer of the
lifeblood podcast he's had me on his
podcast several times he hit the 2000
episode Mark and I thought that's so
cool that we we probably should do
something to celebrate it so we had a
cool conversation together
I did a couple Sadler's stories which
you can find linked to below all these
things are uh in the video description I
did a caption contest about a
checkerboard out in the middle of the
street and a lot of core concept videos
so we finished up the sequence on
Aristotle's Poetics then we did a piece
for my business ethics classes Robert
Audi who's a great ethicist in general
but particularly in the area of business
ethics his piece on cost benefit
analysis and we started something new
that I've been promising to get to for a
long time a manual cons prologomina to
any future metaphysics and it's going to
take me a couple dozen videos probably
to get through that entire work we've
only gotten through the preface so far
but you know that's that's something
right and podcast work
um did some other stuff for business
ethics Norman Bowie and other major
thinker uh we we did some of his stuff
on conscient Ethics in business and
Jasper Hospers his piece what is
libertarianism he actually is quite an
important person in the movement
we did aquinas's five ways from
somoteologia
uh Prima pars question two
Plato's Republic Book 2 for my ethics
classes and now we have started a whole
sequence on Aristotle's categories a
text that I shot an entire sequence of
videos on years back I'm converting them
all into podcast episodes so you can
listen to them wherever you want so that
is it for the month of September quite a
busy month let's talk now about the
month to come
all right so what do we have coming up
in October so next weekend on the 7th
which is Saturday at noon I'll have my
usual AMA that's asked me anything
session you can just pop in and ask
whatever questions you want make sure
that you get in early because we always
get more questions than I can ever get
to and of course you don't need to ask
ask the question more than once it's in
the feed I see it and I'll try to get to
as many as I can following that from my
patreon supporters I will be having our
monthly philosophy chat I hope that you
can join me for that then on the 12th at
uh 7 PM we'll be having that chatting
with nut session now that's not on my
channel that's on Jimmy nuts channel so
we'll put some announcements about that
ahead of time but you could go over
there right now and check out the stuff
that he's got he's got a lot of great
booktube matters on sci-fi horror
fantasy and other areas of speculative
fiction including some really cool
interviews with authors
on the 14th speaking of speculative
fiction we will have sessions 74 of the
worlds of speculative fiction so join me
for a video premiere with live chat
followed by a zoom conversation it's
about three hours total between the
video and the zoom so it's a lot of
opportunity for interaction the series
that we're looking at this time n.k
jemisin's broken Earth Trilogy just an
amazing set of books that I uh have
really really enjoyed they were a
recommendation from a friend of mine who
uh you know year after year kept
recommending them I'm so glad that I
actually finally took her advice and and
read my way through them because boy are
they are they something on the 15th at
noon that's a Sunday we will be resuming
our story time with Sadler that's me
doing a live reading of one of my
favorite short stories and we're going
to keep up the Cat theme that we
established earlier in the series we're
going to be looking at one of HP
lovecraft's short stories the cats of
ulthar which is you know a good
cautionary tale why you should never
mess with somebody's kitten so perhaps
you want to join me for that and then on
the 21st we have the big annual stoicon
starts at 9 00 a.m Central Time all the
times that I'm listening by the way our
central time so you're going to want to
check your time zone I will be coming on
at 1 15 to do my 30 minute presentation
about things of Beauty in stoic text and
talking about you know why we find them
beautiful the entire conference though
is about stoicism and Beauty so it's
going to be a really cool stoicon this
time around and then we'll finish up the
month on the 28th that's a Saturday at
noon we will be getting to the next
session of understanding anger 2.0 and
we're going to be looking at anger in
echelus's plays the orastea at the
trilogy that centers around the house of
Agamemnon with orestes his son being one
of the key characters and the beginnings
of legal justice and the intervention of
Athena and several other gods involved
in that so really great stuff coming up
classes are of course still ongoing I'm
quite busy with those you know I'm I'm
in the classroom three days a week
nowadays
got a lot of client work that I'm doing
as well and I'm going to be continuing
my writing work I got a couple irons in
the fire for that as well as invitations
to write pieces and in various venues
um video works so I've got to get to the
book reviews that I haven't gotten to
for a while and start doing at least
three or four this month you know
getting getting some of these things out
of my backlog there'll be videos of
course of the various events including
I'll I'll record my part of the stoicon
and then I want to do some more of these
ideas that matter interview videos and
that's a matter of lining up the people
who I want to interview I've got a few
people in mind already that I'm going to
be reaching out to I'm going to do some
more Sadler stories perhaps some other
personal videos and possibly some other
quick takes videos on topics that I
think could be useful for me to give my
Reflections on but a lot of what I'm
going to be doing this month is getting
those core concept videos done on kant's
prologomina and that is probably going
to take me most of the rest of this this
month because I'm anticipating you know
probably at least two dozen I don't have
the entire uh series plotted out but
there's there's going to be quite a lot
of of these videos because I'm going to
go through the entire work I'm not
skipping over any of the key topics
because you know it's a very important
text
podcast uh I've got a lot of podcast
work to do on Aristotle's categories you
know I I think I shot something like
you know 20-something videos on that and
I've only released I want to say about
three or four of the podcast episodes so
far so I've got a lot more yet to do and
then we'll see what I'm gonna do with
the podcast after that there's a lot of
other texts that I probably need to get
to sometime soon that I'm you know I've
already got in core concept video form
and I need to turn them into podcast
episodes so that is what we've got
coming up in October I hope that you can
join me for some of these online events
you know the uh conversation that I'll
be having with Jimmy Nutz about Philip K
dick if you're into him you don't want
to miss that uh stoicon obviously very
important uh yearly event that I think
anybody can benefit from and there's all
sorts of other cool stuff coming up as
well so I hope I see you in some of
these events and I hope you have a great
month ahead